[Musique]
excellente source de protéines et de
fibres les légumineuses apporte
cependant pour beaucoup de gens leur lot
d'un confort les légumineuses
contiennent des sucres complexes les
enzymes de notre intestin et les
cellules de notre intestin vont
travailler plus qu'avec d'autres
aliments pour pouvoir justement assimilé
ces sucres complexes qui a dans les
légumineuses le gros intestin
là où il ya le plus de bactéries de
notre flore intestinale
c'est ce microbiote là qui va finir de
digérer les sucres pour nous ça va
provoquer une production de gaz
c'est pour ça que les légumineuses font
partie des aliments qu'on appelle flood
maps
le f dans cet acronyme veut dire
fermentiscibles la fermentation qui
causent le ballonnement est pratiquement
inévitable lorsqu'on mange des
légumineuses ou d'autres aliments
fermentiscibles comme le chou le chou de
bruxelles où le brocoli quoi faire alors
si on veut les introduire dans notre
alimentation
il faut commencer tranquillement puis on
va y aller avec les lentilles sans
légumes gaz de gens sans ressources
dessus aussi en mangeant on va peut-être
pas au bord de la liqueur ou du père y
était des trucs qui ont du gaz à
l'intérieur on s'habitue tranquillement
qui on persévère
ensuite on pourrait aller dans une
catégorie niveau 2 qui seraient pas
cassés exemple les haricots mungo ou
encore utiliser la farine de pois
chiches
tout se passe bien on peut aller au
niveau 3 qui sait
notre catégorie de doliques haricots
pois chiche
oui le trempage design ce qui pourrait
aider encore plus ce serait de faire ce
que j'appelle cuisson est clair c'est
qu'on va prendre l'exemple et haricots
on les met dans un chaudron d'eau en
porte à ébullition taton tient une
évolution pour deux minutes
ensuite on laisse reposer les haches qu
on en fait une heure après ça on va
éviter donc on va enlever cette eau là
on va remettre de l'eau fraîche et là on
va faire notre cuisson des coups comme
kominsky si on se procure des
légumineuses en conserve
elles sont déjà cuites donc prêtes à
l'emploi cette marinade là va déjà un
peu commencé à découper ses sucres
complexes que sont dans les légumineuses
voir les faire sortir un peu du poids de
la lentille ou de la fais en fonction de
la de la can qu'on achète donc la
légumineuse sera moins intéressante du
point de vue nutritionnel mais sera
beaucoup beaucoup plus facile à digérer
[Musique]
on pourrait commencer avec un
d'ajustement soit avec des lentilles
corail ou avec des lentilles hmong il ya
les salade de lentilles qui sont bien
appréciés que si on s'en tient avec une
vinaigrette post sucré ça peut être une
bonne façon c'est d'intégrer les
légumineuses dans notre alimentation
après ça on irait avec les mijotés style
chili ou même la soupe aux pois ça ça
serait une façon aussi de consommer
niveau 2 ensuite on irait vers le plus
difficile à digérer quelque chose on
comprend comment on recommande pas
quelqu'un qui commence l'introduction
des légumineuses dans son alimentation
c'est vraiment l'exemple de nos been au
sirop d'érable ou à la mélasse le
mélange sucré et légumineuses c'est pas
heureux ça non c'est un peu explosif
comme idée on retiendra donc d'y aller
graduellement d' éviter de mélanger avec
du sucre et les aliments gazogène et
diversifier notre alimentation à force
de manger de manière diverse n
équilibrée y compris des aliments
fermentés et de temps en temps des cures
de probiotiques
on va modifier la qualité de sa flore
intestinale et on va comme vous disiez
tantôt peut-être un peu entraîné notre
flore intestinale à mieux digérer les
aliments fermentiscibles dont les
légumineuses
[Musique]
depuis longtemps dans certaines cultures
on utilise la graines de fenouil les
paillotes la coriandre ou la sarriette
pour faciliter la digestion des
légumineuses sans dire que ça ne
fonctionne pas nous n'avons trouvé
aucune évidence scientifique à l'effet
que ce soit vraiment le cas